E
CHINESE NATIONALS IN RETURN TO
NEXT TO NOTHING WITH NO
EXPERTISE OTHER THAN A
CONNECTION TO HIS VICE PRESIDENT
FATHER AT THE TIME.
HERE WITH MORE ARE THE SENATORS
BEHIND THE KEY REPORT, WISCONSIN
SENATOR RON JOHNSON ALONG WITH
IOWA SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY.
GENTLEMEN, GREAT TO SEE YOU
BOTH.
I WILL START WITH YOU,
SENATOR JOHNSON, IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN WHAT WE NOW KNOW, IS
THERE ANYTHING IN MY MONOLOGUE
THAT YOU HEARD THAT IS NOT TRUE
AND WHAT ELSE ARE YOU LEARNING
AS YOU DICTATE DEEPER IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
>> WE'VE KNOWN THIS.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE HAD
INQUIRING MINDS, WE'VE HAD THIS
CLOSE TO TWO YEARS NOW.
IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT HUNTER'S
LAPTOP WAS AUTHENTIC.
STARTING TO SEE INFORMATION FROM
IT.
BUT THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
COMPLICIT.
A FEW MORE DETAILS COME HUNTER
BIDEN KNEW EXACTLY WHO HE WAS
DEALING WITH.
HE CALLED PATRICK "THE SPY CHIEF
IN CHINA."
DEVON ARCHER, WE'VE PROVED THAT
HE WAS INVOLVED IN A FIGHT
AGAINST INDIAN TRIBES.
HE WAS CONVICTED OF THAT.
DEVON ARCHER MET WITH JOE BIDEN
IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN APRIL OF
2014, RIGHT AROUND THE EXACT
SAME TIME IN A COUPLE OF DAYS
AND WHEN DEVON ARCHER BECAME A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE REASON, A
FEW WEEKS LATER HUNTER BIDEN
BECAME A BORED LEADER.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS TANGLED WEB,
A VAST WEB OF FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS AND WE'VE KNOWN
THIS ALL ALONG AND AS TONY
BELINSKY SAID, JOE BIDEN IS
COMPROMISED.
CANCELS ANNOYED STREAM TO
PIPELINE, CANCEL THE CHINA
INITIATIVE WHICH IS A DOJ
INVESTIGATION INTO UNIVERSITIES
OF CHINESE STEALING OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY DIRTY BUT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS BEEN
COMPLICIT, COVERING IT UP.
WHAT "THE WASHINGTON POST"
LEARNED FROM ITS NIXON COVERAGE
IS WHEN YOU'VE BEEN CAUGHT
COVERING THINGS UP, YOU DO A
MODIFIED LIMITED HANGOUT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DATED.
THEY AREN'T REVEALING ALL THE
INFORMATION.
MINIMAL INFORMATION FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
JUST COVERING THEIR "YOU KNOW
WHAT."
>> Sean: YOUR REPORT IN
NOVEMBER OF 2020 WHICH WE
COVERED EXTENSIVELY, YOU POINTED
OUT OVER THE COURSE OF YOUR
INVESTIGATION INTO HOW HUNTER
BIDEN WOULD USE HIS FATHER'S
POSITION AND NAME TO ENRICH
HIMSELF AND HIS FATHER, AND THE
FACT THAT IN THESE EMAILS FROM
THIS LAPTOP, WE CAN NOW CONFIRM
THAT JOE BIDEN BENEFITED
FINANCIALLY FROM IT.
ALSO, JOE BIDEN LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN HE SAID HE
NEVER HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
HUNTER ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
YOU TELL ME, SENATOR.
THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST RODEO ON
ISSUES LIKE THIS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE PAID A PLAYER
CORRUPTION TO ME.
>> WELL, WE HAVE BANK RECORDS
THAT BACK UP EVERYTHING IS IN
THE LAPTOP, AND THEY VERY
CLEARLY SHOW THAT THERE WERE
THESE BANK RECORDS THAT TIED
HUNTER BIDEN DIRECTLY WITH
PEOPLE IN CHINA, BUSINESS PEOPLE
IN CHINA THAT ARE DIRECTLY
CONNECTED WITH THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, THE GOVERNMENT,
AND TO SOME EXTENDS THE CARRIER
SERVICE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
BUT THE REALLY SAD THING IS THE
MEDIA SHOULD'VE BEEN DOING THEIR
JOB IN AUGUST 2019 WHEN I
STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION AND
INSTEAD OF WHAT THEY WERE DOING,
THEY WERE PEDDLING THE
INFORMATION THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WERE PUTTING OUT, WE WERE
PEDDLING RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
AND NOW WE KNOW IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA THAT WAS
BACKING, THE ONES PEDDLING THE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> Sean: COULD YOU IMAGINE,
SENATOR JOHNSON, IF THE LAST
NAME HAD BEEN TRUMP.
WHAT YOU SAID EARLIER THIS WEEK
IS THAT YOU DISCOVERED, YOU AND
SENATOR GRASSLEY, MONEY FROM THE
SEC WHICH IS AN ARM OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT WENT DIRECTLY
TO HUNTER BIDEN.
THERE IS A SHOPPING SPREE
INVOLVED, $5 MILLION INVOLVED,
I'M NOT SURE WHY THEY WOULDN'T
GO TO GOLDMAN SACHS OR
DEUTSCHE BANK, OR
JPMORGAN CHASE, A REAL COMPANY.
I DON'T SEE ANY EXPERIENCE HE
HAD.
BUT THESE HAVE TIES DIRECTLY TO
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
DOES IT NOT?
AND MILITARY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
XI JINPING, THE CHAIRMAN, HE
JUST WENT MISSING.
IT'S A MULTIMILLION OIL AND GAS
COMPANY GOES PROOF.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN WITH A
LEGITIMATE COMPANY.
THAT'S COMPANY CONTROLLED BY THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE PARTY.
LET'S FACE IT.
5 MILLION, A MILLION,
3.5 MILLION FROM MARIE'S MOTHER?
WE ARE UP OVER $13 BILLION OR
WHAT?
WHAT QUALIFIED HUNTER BIDEN FROM
GETTING ALL THAT MONEY.
HIS NAME.
HE WAS INFLUENCE PEDDLING.
THIS IS THE SLEAZIEST THING THAT
I'VE SEEN IN POLITICS.
I WANT TO REALLY THANK
SENATOR GRASSLEY FOR HIS
TENACIOUS NESTS IN HELPING
INVESTIGATE THIS.
WE'VE GOT A PRETTY GOOD TEAM.
BY THE WAY, WE BOTH HAD TOUGH
REELECTIONS.
CHUCK IS GrassleyWorks.com.
HE WORKS VERY HARD.
IF YOU WANT TO GET ALL THE STUFF
EXPOSED, NEED SOME HELP.
>> Sean: SENATOR GRASSLEY,
THIS IS THE MAIN QUESTION.
JOE BIDEN LIED WHEN HE SAID HE
HAS NO KNOWLEDGE.
WE KNOW THAT IS ALIVE.
AS IT RELATES TO RUSSIA,
KAZAKHSTAN, UKRAINE AND CHINA,
IS IT POSSIBLE WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT IS COMPROMISED, THAT THEY
HAVE PERSONAL INFORMATION,
POTENTIALLY BLACKMAIL
INFORMATION ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN
HUNTER BIDEN, FORMER CRACK
ADDICT.
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION,
SENATOR?
>> IT IS A FAIR QUESTION AND
IT'S A QUESTION WITH ME BUT
EVERY AMERICAN OUGHT TO KEEP IT
IN THE BACK OF HIS MIND, AS
PARTICULARLY AS OUR GOVERNMENT
IS DEALING WITH THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
NUMBER ONE COMPETITOR IN THE
WORLD AND THE NUMBER TWO ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AND I THINK IT'S
LEGITIMATE TO RAISE THAT
QUESTION.
I WISH I COULD SAY ABSOLUTELY
YES.
BUT FOR SOMEBODY TO SAY THAT
OVER THE YEARS THAT THE EIGHT
YEARS OF BEING VICE PRESIDENT
AND ALSO OF BEING OUT OF OFFICE
BUT STILL HAVING THE BIDEN NAME
AND THE PRESTIGE OF THAT, THAT
YOU NEVER TALK THIS WITH YOUR
FAMILY.
THAT'S LIKE MY SON AND I ARE IN
FARMING.
WE TALK ABOUT FARMING ALL THE
TIME.
>> Sean: EXACTLY.
SAME QUESTION, SENATOR JOHNSON.
WE LEARNED THAT LIBYA HAD A
DOSSIER AND LEARNED ALL ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN'S ISSUES.
I'M BEING KIND.
ISN'T IT LIKELY THAT THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE AND THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS AND ALL
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE A
DOSSIER ON JOE, HUNTER BIDEN,
AND THE REST OF THE FAMILIES IN
THE THAT PUTS THEM ON POTENTIAL
BLACKMAIL.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> WE MAY NOT KNOW ALL THE
DETAILS.
BUT I TELL YOU WHO DOES.
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE, CHINESE
INTELLIGENCE, IRANIAN
INTELLIGENCE, NORTH KOREAN
INTELLIGENCE.
MY GUESS IS THAT THERE ARE
ELEMENTS IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY THAT KNOW AS WELL.
THEY AREN'T GOING TO TELL US.
THEY WON'T TELL THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC BECAUSE THERE IS
CORRUPTION IN THE DEEP STATE.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR INFORMATION
FROM GINA HASPEL OUT.
SHE WOULDN'T EVEN RETURN OUR
PHONE CALLS OR TELL US WHY SHE
WOULDN'T RESPOND TO OUR
LEGITIMATE REQUESTS.
IT'S VERY DEEP STATE, PERVASIVE,
IT IS FILLED WITH LIBERAL
LEFTISTS.
THAT'S ONE OF OUR BIG PROBLEMS
AND IS COUNTRY TODAY.
>> Sean: IF THAT'S TRUE WE
HAVE POTENTIALLY A COMPROMISED
PRESIDENT POTENTIALLY, HIS
FAMILY SUBJECT TO BLACKMAIL OR
THEY HAVE SOM